la frontière deuxième partie aujourd'hui
la typologie des frontières les
premières fraudes tiers auxquels on peut
penser ce sont les frontières dites
naturelles c'est à dire qu'un élément
naturel va permettre de délimiter deux
territoires
on peut penser notamment à la frontière
à la frontière franco espagnole qui est
constituée par le massif pyrénéen
de même en france toujours la france est
séparé de l'italie par les alpes donc le
relief constitue un élément qui peut
être constitutif d'une frontière
naturelle les montagnes le relief donc
mais aussi l'hydrographie c'est à dire
les cours d'eau en europe de l'est par
exemple la slovaquie et la hongrie sont
séparée par le danube la frontière
correspond au cours du danube
on peut avoir aussi en opposition à
cette frontière naturelle une frontière
artificielle qu'on appellera aussi
politique
c'est le cas notamment de beaux coups
d'état qui ont été constituées après la
décolonisation donc ici par exemple en
afrique du nord
vous voyez les frontières entre la libye
l'egypte le tchad le soudan sont
clairement artificielles ne
correspondent à rien c'est juste une
décision qui a été prise un certain
moment de les mettre là plutôt
qu'ailleurs ses frontières artificielles
peuvent être évidemment géométriques
c'est le cas par exemple de la frontière
entre le canada les etats-unis qui
correspond vraiment à une ligne droite
où certaines frontières des états au
sein des états unis voyez ici par
exemple qu'entre le kansas et l'oklahoma
on a vraiment une frontière rectiligne
alors ce qui est intéressant voire
séparation entre les différents états
aux états unis on peut avoir des
frontières comme ça qui sont totalement
géométriques ou des frontières
naturelles
c'est le cas par exemple entre ligne
diana et le kentucky ou loriot forme la
frontière
la frontière peut être aussi décidé à
partir d'éléments entrepôt géographique
entre poste c'est l'homme y donc des
éléments vraiment de géographie humaine
ça peut être le cas quand on a deux
communautés qui parlent une langue
différente
là où l'on change de landes en quelque
sorte va constituer l'endroit où on va
placer lapointe caire alors nous nous
connaissons très bien ça en belgique
puisque la frontière linguistique que
vous voyez ici qui a un peu plus de 50
ans mais est ce vraiment un exemple de
cette frontière de ses frontières
entrepôts géographique mais on pourrait
éventuellement imaginer d'autres
critères que simplement le critère
linguistique
ça peut être bien sûr le critère
ethnique religieux qui peuvent fournir
de base à une frontière entre pôles
géographiques une frontière qu'elle soit
naturelle géométriques ou autres pôles
géographiques
c'est toujours une convention c'est
alors que c'est toujours une décision
d'humains qui décide de créer une
séparation à cet endroit là alors ici
vous voyez par exemple des images prises
dans à partir de google earth la
frontière franco-belge au niveau de
gognies-chaussée donc c'est un set au
sud de monde vous voyez que la frontière
c'est une route la frontière correspond
au tracé d'une route mais qui est
vraiment situe en plein champ il n'y a
aucun élément physique qui permet de
distinguer si ce n'est la route est
tracée par les hommes autres autre cas
ici une des frontières libyennes en
plein désert qui ne correspond vraiment
aucun élément donc c'est vraiment une
décision des hommes de placer les
frontières ces endroits là
on a évidemment les frontières physiques
les frontières physiques ont déjà parlé
dans les frontières naturelles les
frontières naturelles sont des
frontières physiques donc la première
physique c'est vraiment une frontière
qui est marqué par un élément des
spasmes éléments spatiale alors ici par
exemple vous avez le rio grande et entre
les états unis et le mexique où ici les
pyrénées frontières physiques mais qui
peut être si construite par l'homme qui
permet de vraiment visualiser cette
frontière on a le mur d'hadrien entre
l'ecosse et l'angleterre
le mur de berlin qui a été détruit en
1989 en fait il reste encore quelques
pans en allemagne et puis bien sûr la
grande muraille de chine qui marquait
des frontières entre différentes ethnies
à différentes époques
voilà nous avons terminé ici un petit
peu le petit parcours sur les différents
types de frontières qu'on peut
rencontrer
n'oubliez pas le test qui suit cette
vidéo et nous parlerons de tout ça en
classe je vous souhaite une bonne
journée et à bientôt